they're rapists and some I assume are
good people the idea of completely
discounting Mexicans and talking about
your second most important trading
partner in that vein we have some bad
umbrage here and we're going to get them
out that's not the art of the deal
veterinary practices
I am Nicol SP for reason and today we
are talking with Roberto Salinas he's
the president of the Mexico business for
him and he's a persistent and vocal
critic of Donald Trump Roberta thanks
for talking to reason it's great
pleasure to be here Nick let's talk
about NAFTA person your role in it is
NAFTA a good thing or a bad thing for
Mexico Canada and the US it's getting a
lot of heat lately in the early 1990s we
thought well wow Mexico is already a
story of trade liberalization were we're
exporting 35 billion dollars of year
worth of products and so on today that
number is 365 billion so from a trade
perspective and this is a trade
agreement from a trade perspective I
don't think there's any question the nap
that has been a success in the sale side
and then you go to the purchase side in
other words imports and you find that
you're also importing a vast amount
guess where those imports come from in
about 80% I'm United States
so does Indiana depend I mean speaking
of mike pence does Indiana depend on
jobs because of its trade with Mexico
does Ohio Texas you want to shut down
NAFTA and that turns Texas into a
democratic state overnight where do you
think the Animus against NAFTA
particularly in the United States and I
mean this is something that Donald Trump
ran on it's also something that Bernie
Sanders brought up a lot the idea that
some have free trade agreements the suck
jobs out of American they put them in
third-world countries which do to a lot
of economic ignorance oftentimes they're
talking about Mexico as a third-world
country as well so where does the
resentment of something like I think
that was one of the great lessons of the
Trump campaign the Bernie Sanders
campaign it's not something that
discriminates between Republicans and
Democrats or between the right or the
left or whatever what you found out is
that there is anger because there's
displacement there is job displacement
and that's a very serious concern but
are we going to address it by close
our economy's by building laws I mean
wasn't another famous Republican the one
who said tear down this wall the same
one that said we will always keep our
doors open in the shiny city on the hill
no matter how many walls it may have I
think those principles have to be kept
in mind but also to be very serious
about trying to alleviate the disruption
and the and the displacement that may
come and was area of globalization for
those that have lost their jobs and you
mentioned Indiana and Ohio you can throw
a Michigan and Wisconsin State er that
were very important for Donald Trump to
win it's clear that the deadly NAFTA
message resonated there how do you help
workers who may have been displaced by
the idea that certain types of
industrial jobs go else oh my goodness
that is a hard question I think you
would have to come in three tranches and
but this is something that's purely
speculative the first is that you need
some some type of hopefully market
oriented job loss insurance that may be
funded through the akin a tremendous
economic exchange that is done enough
trilateral basis only on a temporary
point of view in other words as just a
measure to alleviate the immediate pain
but then you need something that's more
structural and that would have to be
based on retraining on education and on
trilateral efforts hopefully more
private oriented than public oriented to
try and find new work spaces for such
people and I think this is something
that independently of NAFTA is an issue
in the United States in the next 10
years with the tremendous advances of
Technology because those job
displacements are a lot more to a
technology technological disruption and
progress than they do to than they do to
right yeah a third-world by the way the
idea that low wages are sucking no no
it's more affordable and more productive
worker units you go down to normalcy or
Sonora where the at the Ford plant there
which is suspended production on one of
its a four models but otherwise Haiti
would be the richest country in Latin
America otherwise of all these many of
these sub-saharan countries would be by
far the most prosperous ones how does
the Mexican business community view
somebody like Donald Trump I mean are
they worried not just because of his red
but that he'll do policies that actually
do real damage to the ability for the
Mexican economy or the North American
economy to grow at first there's a
significant worry PC we have to
understand that NAFTA from Mexico was
much more than a trade and an investment
agreement
it was importing the credibility of us
institutions if you do investment on a
North American level chances of a future
government than Mexico trying to derail
that as it happened to us before are
going to be a lot harder
so that's straitjacket effect perhaps is
not golden but it's certainly a silver
straitjacket somebody may want to renal
eyes reacts procreate the banks or they
may want to do all kinds of horrible
things in the populist tradition of that
has characterized many Latin American
countries NAFTA was a great step forward
in trying to not preclude that
completely but significantly lessened
the probability of a future change and
that's what led to a great deal of
investment coming into Mexico it was
that credibility that was important in
that sense for Mexico the idea of
abandoning NAFTA was still trade with
the United States at an enormous level
you know Mexico today is the number one
supplier of auto parts in the United
States the number two supplier of
automobiles of the United States NFL
helmets are produced in Mexico assembled
in Mexico
pretty sure avocados or you guys have
corner of the emerging our greatest lie
a fake nose can even color at that it's
just an outright lie
for the facts speak very differently
about the effect of NAFTA on Mexican
agriculture on the country it's exploded
it's exploded and I arrived I myself
have friends and and and many people
that I don't know this from reading a
statistic I know this from actually
visiting the different farms whether
it's tomato you know many of the
tomatoes reading the best restaurants in
Las Vegas or in New York or in Los
Angeles they come from seen that off so
you're saying Mexican tomatoes or taking
American Tomatoes jobs no no you know
I'm not saying I went on Sonya I'm
saying the Donald Trump when he goes and
needs a Danielle balut he doesn't know
it is very expensive dinner that he is
actually the one that's unemploy
American now why should the room for
both why don't you look
consumers choose at the end of the day
this leads I think to a great deal of
fallacies concerning the trade deficit
that mean the the intellectual backwards
of many of trumps trade advisors
contrast dramatically with some of the
very good advice he's gotten in terms of
deregulation and in terms of taxes and
in terms of draining the swamp when
Donald Trump announced for the
presidency within literally within five
minutes he went on a rant they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists and some I assume are
good people
what kind of anger does that her
resentment does that stir in in you or
in Mexicans broadly along with it
increasingly xenophobic rhetoric both
coming out of the Republican Party but
many other parts of America
I'll tell you what it has done it has
empowered under his Lopez Obrador
who is our equivalent of ovo Chavez a
rabid primitive vitriolic populist he's
on the top for the 2018 presidential
election today he's leading on the polls
and that's that's because he has Donald
Trump became his number-one campaign
advisor with that vitriol so instead of
talking to each other because that's
usually what classical liberals do they
learn how to talk to each other and
listen to each other the idea of
completely discounting Mexicans and
talking about your second most important
trading partner in that vein is just
that's not the art of the deal that is
just very bad business there's other
ways of going around it look at the
Republican Doug Ducey in Arizona
talking bateau there pablovich in Sonora
they don't no longer want to distinguish
the states they want to talk about the
mega region and how they can complement
each other is what comparative advantage
is Donald Trump ever heard that word
this petering a viral ever read Adam
Smith David Ricardo we're speaking at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas the world's
largest annual gathering of libertarians
and pre-market people two years ago
Donald Trump actually spoke here and you
had a heated exchange with him you asked
him a tough question recount for us what
the question was what his response was
and you know do you feel like you got
through it all well no I actually I felt
rather humiliated the man does know how
to
manage the stage and what I asked him
was whether he would build a wall out of
every in every single state within the
United States to keep Nebraska bad
hombres out of Missouri and and the bad
element of Florida out of Washington
State and what that would do to the
economy because by that logic that's
where you should do and for that matter
municipalities and whatnot and so he
said no he would he would build a wall
just for Mexico and he accused me of
being sent by the Mexican government did
the government of Mexico ask you to come
up well like they were supporting okay
go ahead ask you a question ask you
question we're going to say that come on
you got a lot of people waiting like
were you in fact sent by the bank of
course I'm going
you were sent by the Russian government
or the Haitian government or maybe the
et er do you feel like xenophobia is on
the rise in in the NAFTA zone I mean are
people in an age where economic growth
you know pretty much globe in many cases
globally has been slowing down certainly
in the United States in the 21st century
economic growth has been much lower than
it had been for the previous 50 or 60
years is that breeding a kind of
resentment or a sense of we're fighting
over a shrinking pie and that we've got
to keep out people who we think aren't
like us or that happy Thomas that I
think is a very important challenge
there's definitely an ingredient of
xenophobia I think we're still in time
to to to curtail it Mexican business
people and the government have learned
that a lot of what Donald Trump says a
lot of the vitriol on the venom are just
that their rhetoric and in reality you
know we'll talk about renegotiating
NAFTA but what does that entail that may
actually provide an opportunity to
develop for instance new technologies to
allow trucks on both sides of the border
to cross maybe a special bridge after
you do you know full disclosure after
after you agree to be completely
surveilled by satellites and whatnot
then maybe that could be pay a little
piece of a wall that will still take 27
years to build or somesuch
by the way probably by mexican workers
and semak's Mexican cement so that may
not be all bad for us but it's the it's
the message is what hurts is you're
going to pay for and I'm going to force
you to pay for it
and that's that's not that's just not
good diplomacy and that feeds that
xenophobia north of the border but it
also feeds it elsewhere Donald Trump is
not a highly regarded leader of the free
world in the rest of the world because
of his antics and because of the reality
TV that he lives in and because of this
fantasy or fryin complex that he might
have that he wants to be number one and
he wants to treat at every moment of the
day that he's that he's number one
that's not how you're going to get
things done that's not the art of the
deal in statements statesmanship and
leader leadership in the in the global
arena we will leave it there but the
final question of course that I ask
anybody from Mexico who is a classical
liberal or libertarian Friedrich Hayek
or Salma Hayek who's your pleasure Hayek
oh my goodness that's an impossible
question but I would have to say
Frederick well I want to thank Roberto
Salinas he is the president of the
Mexico Business Forum for talking to us
while we're at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas
Roberta thanks so much Thank You Nick
for reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]